bu
bu A harfini tanıyorsunuz üzerinde iki
nokta olduğu zaman biz bunu evde yokuz
aynı maçında olduğu gibi e harfinin
biraz uzatarak okuyoruz Şimdi de yanına
Bu harfini getirelim eu bu iki harf oy
olarak okunur aynı şekilde Evet bu
harfleri de yan yana gelince oy olarak
okunur Öyleyse gelsin halay müziği
zaman bu kadar yeter şimdi a ve onun
üzerindeki noktaları atalım a ve unu Bir
de ayın çıktığını düşünün Bir saniye ya
yoksa dolunay mı
avg-u kurt adama dönüştü Demek ki bu iki
harfi av şeklinde okumalıyız
c harfleri HD olarak okunur en ince
sesli harfler ile birlikte O da incelir
iş birşeye dönüşür kalın sesli harflerle
de kalınlaşır
Doğa Ah çok gibi okunur burayı tanırken
söylediğimiz ah vah gibi kelimeler sanki
bu harflerle yazılmış gibidir bir
CHP'nin yanına S gelirse ne olur tur
olur tilki kelimesini Fox olarak
okumalıyız books olarak değil
önceki harflerini İngilizce'den
bilirsiniz o Jack sparrow'un ismindeki
keke çift k gibi okun iyi
bakın kelimesi Buna örnek olabilir
Evet Ee harfi normal okunur Ama
kelimenin sonlarına doğru halden hale
girer
mesela sonlarda evre harfleri A harfine
dönüşür annemize motor değil mut'ta
deriz babamıza ise sağ tel yerine Fatiha
deriz evden sonra L ya da ne harfleri
gelirse ı harfi gibi okunur
on-call yerine 10K demek daha güzel olur
Bir de fiiller de mastar hal vardır bu
kelimeler nasıl biter bu kelimeler
verene harfi ile bitter bunu da olarak
okumak daha iyi olur bilen yerine şu
diyelim diyelim
Eee harfleri ay gibi okunur bural manca
da ay yumurta demek Türkçede ise
Gökyüzünde Parlayan uydumuz demek
O ne lan şu anda tanırsınız O da ayağa
aşık olmuş ve Neil ismindeki Eee
harflerini aya taşımış ve adını oraya
kazanmış
S.A.V iyi eve ilgili yaygın kullanılmasa
da ay şeklinde okunur
burma'ya kelimesinde olduğu gibi tek
başına h harfi başlangıçta işe yarar
Halo hem skiibii ama ortalarda ve
sonlarda ortadan kaybolur var mı yok mu
anlayamazsınız ğ gibi ortada dolanıp
durur iyi vee iyi şekilde uzatılır
Siemens de olduğu gibi j harfi
çoğunlukla ye harfine dönüşür Pekiyi
harfine ne olur Almanca'da y ile
başlayan kelime pek bulamazsınız şu yağ
yağ yağ olarak okunur
B harflerini İngilizce'den bilirsiniz H
harfine dönüşür mesela filozofta olduğu
gibi
uyku Türkçede yok ama siz İngilizce'den
bu harfi tanıyorsunuz zaten bu diye
okunur
bak
bak kelimesinde olduğu gibi s harfinin
hikayesi çok başlarda seyahatinin kafası
zehir gibi yani bir Z gibi çalışır
subede ki s harfi Z ye dönüşür zubbe
diye okuruz
Sonlara doğru zehir gibi olan s yorulur
ve emekli olur yani özüne döner
vaz kelimesi yine Vas yokmuş
çifte yani sese yine bu şekilde okunur
fakat yazarken bunu Esed denilen bu
garip harfle yazabilirsiniz
sch Bunlar hırsız Çetesi
Selami Cumali Hayri bu Uçucu bir araya
geldiğinde aralarında konuştukları tek
şey
sesidir bir Yani sch şey olarak okunur
bu Schweinsteiger da olduğu gibi
travmatik s harfinin çocuklara bir
inelim yanına p yani Pakize ninesi ve T
yani tahsil birisi geldiğinde şımarır ve
şey harfine dönüşür
bu kelimeyi spiel değil şu pil olarak ve
bunu da stop değil şu top olarak
okumalıyız
senin hikayesi hiç bitmez demiştim size
hikayeyi iyice karıştırıp güzel
bitirelim
senin sonuna t harfini koyalım sağına da
CH gelsin okuyalım şimdi ç ç bitti bu
kadar bara aynı öğrenmeye çalıştığımız
Doğuş kelimesi gibi
t&h yine T şeklinde okunur aynı Tolga
yöresindeki gibi B harfi Almanca'da
genellikle T şeklinde okunur volkswa bu
şeklinde yazılır ama Fox bakın şeklinde
telaffuz edilir çift V harfinin ve
şeklinde okuduğunu zaten biliyorsunuz
ilk s harfi ise kız şeklinde okunur aynı
aslanmax ta olduğu gibi s harfi sinsidir
tuz şeklinde okunur aynı bir yılının
tıslaması gibi
biz iPhone değil Say Tong ders
abone ol
[Müzik]